who will blink first poland and the eu
are playing chicken and the fate of both
is at stake this week the european court
of justice slapped its highest ever fine
a million euros a day on warsaw after
the country's constitutional tribunal
ruled that the polish constitution takes
precedence over the eu treaty the head
of the eu commission says the fine is a
legitimate response to a ruling that
challenges the very basis of the
european legal order blackmail says
poland's prime minister marvyetsky
it's only the latest in ongoing tensions
that includes security on poland's
easternmost border where guards are
accused of illegally pushing back
undocumented migrants trafficked into
europe by belarus
our topic on to the point europe's next
domino will pole exit follow brexit
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it's a
pleasure to greet our guests worship
shimanski works in the polish editorial
office here at dw and he says the eu
cannot allow poland to undermine its
legal system but also cannot risk losing
its own popularity there also great to
have on the show andreas kloot he's a
correspondent and columnist at bloomberg
opinion and he says poland's rebellion
shows that the eu either needs a proper
constitution or the power to kick out
member states
and i'm very pleased to welcome our
correspondent in brussels uh for dw
alexander fun naman and she says if
poland gets away with challenging the
poor principles of the eu the european
project as a whole
is in jeopardy
and alexandra from the sound of that it
sounds as if you're saying it's make or
break for the eu why is that
yes you're right it is a crucial moment
for the european union because poland is
questioning is challenging fundamental
values the european union was funded on
and the problem is that it's not only
about poland the problem is that our
countries could follow and could say hey
why do we need to uh respect the rule of
law or do we really need to
respect free media so that's why the
european union cannot
let poland get away with that and cannot
say okay let's just talk about that we
are not going to do anything because
this is such a crucial issue for the
european union
worship you say that the eu can't risk
losing popularity in poland but is there
really any danger of that tens of
thousands of people have gone out onto
the streets across the country to demand
that poland stay in the eu i would say
not yet well poland is a very
pro-european country and people in
poland want to stay in the european
union there are surveys saying that more
than 80 percent of people in poland are
really happy about being the part of the
european union but we see that the
european commission has started playing
hard ball in this conflict with warso
among
the judiciary and rule of law and my
concern is that if there are some new
fines and poland has to pay a lot of
money for this uh judiciary
for the reform of judiciary i'm afraid
that the government in poland some day
will try to convince people it is the
bad european union it's the bad brussels
which is taking our money away from us
that's why for example there is no
enough money for for for normal people
and everything is getting more expensive
i'm afraid that the government if this
conflict goes on someday could
try to use this narrative
internationalist populist populist
way andreas your opening statement says
that the eu needs a proper constitution
does that mean that you think that the
commission the eu commission actually
doesn't have currently the legal
competence to play hardball as they're
doing
um
it it should play hardball i'm not
saying that but um
if you
poland is clearly like hungary in the
wrong here because of its motivations
for this step but what i am saying is
that the step there's rebellion this
declaration that polish law is supreme
to uh eu law
but
but with that rebellion poland is
putting its finger on a central
ambiguity that plagues the european
project the eu european union a design
flaw as it were because the european
union really is
trapped
between being a federal state like
germany or the us and just of a
confederation of states a loose a club
of nations like the united nations it's
not clear which
and
therefore it's also not clear whether
from the european treaties because the
eu doesn't have a constitution from the
european treaties it's not clear
exactly what is the relationship the
hierarchical relationship of the
european court of justice luxembourg and
the national courts so this issue keeps
coming up and this is just the most
blunt
way it has come up and therefore either
the eu has to decide it will go forward
become a federation and give itself the
constitution which has tried and failed
to do in the past or and i think that's
more likely it has to say well if we're
going to be a club then like every other
club or most other clubs we have to have
a way of kicking out members if they
don't play by the rules now i want to
come back to that design error in a
moment but first let's take a closer
look at the current dispute the eu has
been protesting for years against
political interference with the courts
brussels says it's a violation of
europe's core democratic principles
judicial independence and rule of law
ever since the national conservative pis
party rose to power in poland it has
been reorganizing the judicial system
constitutional judges it considers too
liberal are being replaced with party
loyal conservatives the presiding judge
is a close confidant of pis boss
kaczynski
and the new judges are delivering
contravening the european court of
justice poland's top court ruled in
october that some eu laws violate the
polish constitution and thus the
sovereignty of the country
from the eu's point of view poland is
shaking a cornerstone of the european
union
it is a direct challenge to the unity
of the european legal order
we cannot and we will not allow
our common values to be put at risk
because of the ruling the eu is
withholding 24 billion euros in
coronavirus development aid for poland
we cannot accept that the eu is
expanding its authority
we will not accept financial sanctions
against poland
who will prevail in this dispute
and let me pass that question straight
on to you uh voice if this is the game
of chicken who do you think will blink
first
um
it's a very difficult question to answer
to be to be honest well i believe that
the european commission has to do
something because
its
main uh
well the european commission should be
they should be protecting the european
uh european law and this law is being
totally ignored now by poland so the
european commission cannot
do nothing it has to react and it
started reacting now
but on the other hand we have this
political situation in poland which
really doesn't allow the government now
to take a step back because
if the government says yeah okay uh
brussels are okay luxembourg okay the
european court of justice you're right
it would
mean that they accept what the polish
constitutional court
says it's not really legal so it's a
very very difficult situation and my
imagination maybe is not enough to tell
you what is really going to happen
thank you very much
alexandra as we heard in that report uh
the poland's prime minister and other
polish leaders say the eu does not have
the authority to take uh this step and
andreas just talked about that design
error the ambiguity in the eu treaties
so how do you see it clearly you believe
politically it's a necessary step but is
it covered by law if you're trying to
uphold rule of law obviously you should
have a very solid legal basis for what
you do
that's true definitely but we have to
say that what the polish government is
challenging are crucial provisions of
the treaties that the european union is
based on and in those treaties you will
find references to the rule of law and
so on so i don't think that we really
have to argue about that that member
countries in the european union have to
be sure about their judiciary
independence
they have to make clear that you are
able to to have independent
judges so
that is why i would say that that the
most
crucial or most uh
pro important problem here is that the
european union was founded as a club of
liberal democracies as a counter-model
to authoritarian regimes and that is why
the european union is not well equipped
to deal with authoritarian or
anti-democratic challenges uh tendencies
within the blog that is why it is so
difficult to to say okay if you are not
ready to play by the rules if you are
not
respecting fundamental european rules
that you just need to leave the club
that is not possible and that is why the
european commission is trying to to to
keep up the dialogue with the polish
government
to to find a solution on the other hand
of course they need
to act if they see see that fundamental
european values are not being respected
alexander one uh quick follow-up to that
uh and it and and the question is this
is there a double standard at work here
germany's own constitutional court has
actually in the past also in a ruling
said that national law takes precedence
over eu policy and nobody was slapping
sanctions on berlin
well actually berlin was slapped with
penalties because of that decision
but it is really a different thing here
because when we talk about the decision
by the german constitutional judges they
just challenged one european decision
they were not challenging uh
the european treaties and the other
thing is that they are considered
independent while in poland there are
doubts about
the judiciary independence in the
country
andreas
from a political point of view did the
eu did the commission have to take this
step at this time certainly there were
eu member states uh who were calling for
further dialogue even including germany
i think the
you cannot not act it cannot let this
stand because um
it will become a precedent
um
and
so in that sense i'm on the side of of
hard rather than soft and i think angela
merkel overshot on the side of soft when
she she spoke out recently
and let me let me ask about that
in fact
angela merkel who has eastern
european roots herself she came from the
gdr former east germany she said in the
course of the recent eu leaders summit
that in fact
she has some understanding for polish
sensitivities about autonomy on the
basis of poland's history essentially uh
being continually oppressed and uh torn
up by russia and or germany how do you
see it
um well of course poland
is really independent now first until
1989 so
this period of independence is shorter
than in some other western european
countries
but come on the european union is not
soviet union we are there because we
wanted to be there polish people wanted
to be there we are not
oppressed by uh by the by the european
union and poland the polish people in i
you know said we want to uh join so i
find this narrative that some polish
politicians use saying oh some uh some
forces from outside are now telling us
what to do
not really accurate this is
it it's free to be in the european union
nobody pushes you to to to be there um
and well yeah angela merkel this is her
way of dealing with issues in the
european union as well not seeking for
too much uh conflict
but now after 16 years of of angela
merkel with her
a lot of successes maybe in the european
politics but also yeah what's the what's
what's going on with hungary what's
going on with poland after years of
saying okay let's don't let escalate
too much
alexander at the polish prime minister's
recent appearance before the eu
parliament
he gave quite a harsh speech and one
german member of the eu parliament
responded by telling him that poland is
sleep walking into exit from the eu
would you agree with that
characterization
well um i don't think that it's really a
realistic option
because as we just heard
eu is
the us as a whole is still very popular
in poland and that is something that the
polish government knows very well
but
the problem is that it just cannot
continue um this dispute
is dividing the european union and there
are so many important challenges ahead
just like think about the climate change
or the fallout of the coronavirus
pandemic so
member states they need each other and
after this recent decision by the
european court of justice that ordered
poland to pay one million euros per day
for um
challenging the rule of law
when we talk in general terms
that is why i think that
now there is a chance that the polish
government could come up with a small
solution
face saving compromise to avoid those
fines and
to
try to
you know to have a solution to this
problem at least for now
and andreas where do you think things go
from here as as you said in your opening
statement the eu actually has no formal
mechanism for throwing out a member
state do you think that this hefty fine
that has been imposed and it's not the
only fine by the way that is confronting
poland do you think that that could
concentrate some mines in warsaw and
lead leaders there to take a kind of a
an exit ramp from the conflict rather
than from the eu itself well first of
all unfortunately the default
approach in the by the european union to
any problem is a sort of muddling
through
uh rather than a decisive uh dealing
with any any issue so i think we're
probably in for some muddling through on
the brussels side
on the warsaw side um
i'm less sure but the the positive
scenario to to solving the the whole
tangled hairball of the problem is that
in hungary next year at an election next
year and in poland at an election in two
years
that the voters there they still they
are compromised democracies but they're
still democracies and if polls and
hungarians decide look
we're tired of this we want to stay that
they vote these governments out then
then we will have remove the blockage
and then reform the club so that it can
expel members in future
if it becomes necessary again and let me
ask you about that uh prospect of
poland of course still does have
elections and um
the fact is it is the biggest net
recipient of eu largesse and it also
stands to benefit
quite massively from the eu pandemic
recovery fund next generation eu
so
what would polish citizens do if in fact
that financial tap
is closed off do you think there would
be uh the peace party would be kicked
out of office
um
i think that the peace party would try
to blame brussels and blame germany and
blame everybody in the world or in the
european union for
uh not giving poland money and for
keeping money which should be paid to to
poland on the other hand
there would be a
big
there will be protests in poland because
we know there are a lot of people who
want to stay in the european union
people in poland would not let this
really happen that the government would
somehow uh pull poland out of the eu but
of course the government says they don't
want to do it because that's that's not
what they are aiming at they want to
stay in the european union but what they
are indirectly doing by uh by
challenging the the most fundamental
laws this is somehow exiting the
european uh common uh common law uh uh
uh environment uh so this is what what
the government this is what the
government is is doing but uh it's hard
to say what will really happen if there
is no more money will the government be
able to convince people it's the fault
of the eu or will the people in poland
see no it is the government which did
the bad job that's why we're not getting
this money which poland really needs and
even the government needs this money
very very much
meanwhile on poland's eastern border
europe's uh current uh currently worst
migration crisis is playing out poland
has been pushing back sometimes
violently against a mass influx of
middle eastern refugees orchestrated by
neighboring belarus
this syrian family has been stranded in
a forest in the border area between
belarus and poland aid workers provided
them with makeshift supplies but that
kind of help is illegal poland has
closed the border area to aid workers
and journalists so the eight workers
don't want to be identified
i've seen a lot of bad things during my
career but not this kind of human
tragedy these people are sitting in the
forest are hungry and half frozen to
death and are pleading for help
organizations say polish soldiers are
forcing refugees back to belarus such
so-called pushbacks are illegal under eu
law but according to polish law they're
now allowed
it's something that
you don't wish for your worst enemy
we've been sleeping in the woods for the
past four days
it's it's
it's like a nightmare
poland is securing the 400 kilometer
border with barbed wire and will later
replace it with a wall
still many refugees have been reaching
germany
interior minister horst zeihofer has
tightened border controls and does not
disagree with poland's planned wall
construction
do the eu partners approve of poland's
actions on its eastern border
and let me take that question straight
to alexandra the eu is happy to sanction
poland when it comes to interfering with
the judiciary but remarkably silent
about the very questionable actions
being taken on that border to belarus
well that is true and the criticism that
has been expressed
doesn't bring any results
commissioner johansen traveled to poland
she offered poland support front texts
uh that frontex should be
participating in what is going on at the
border to belarus security guard yeah
yeah thank you for explaining that uh
sorry uh yes and and uh poland didn't
want them uh to come and so there is
some criticism uh
poland is facing for what it is doing at
the border with belarus for pushing back
migrants uh back to belarus for not
letting journalists and ngos enter the
zone that is covered by the emergency
state however when we talk
about the support among member states
this is pretty much there many member
states say
it is important to protect
our external borders we need to support
poland we cannot let lukashenko uh the
belarusian
belarusian dictator
we cannot let him send migrants into the
european union that needs to stop and
that is why we need to support poland
mr lukashenko is doing this essentially
to take revenge against europe for the
sanctions it has imposed on its regime
is the eu leaving poland in the lurch by
not standing up to likoshenko more
forcefully
well if polish diplomacy was
maybe able to act more actively in the
european union and in the world maybe it
would be able to create some more
pressure on uh kashenko and also
probably on russia because
with i think it's not only belarus maybe
russia also involved in this in this
operation but as we've we've heard
poland
refuse the help from this european
security agency poland wants to try to
secure the border uh on its own so i
don't hear voices in poland saying now
oh european union help us
that's not the narrative now
let me step back uh and uh ask you
andreas for a wider perspective on this
angela merkel will soon be stepping down
and there are voices saying that just at
this moment when europe
faces multiple crises that it is
leaderless do you think that's right
that europe is leaderless yes i think
that's um i think it was always
exaggerated how much merkel was the
leader of europe um but
some people i mean emmanuel macron
president of france would like to
present himself as the leader but he's
not being accepted as such by the other
nations mario draghi prime minister of
italy has enormous gravitas from his
time as ecb a governor is very
pro-american very good in english but
could play that role but in general i
think you're right it probably looks
like europe will remain leaderless for
some time
let me come back to our title we have
just uh about one minute left on the
clock but i want to just put that
question out there again uh will poll
exit follow brexit what's your guess
alexandra
i don't think so
i know that we will be dealing with this
problem for a longer time but i don't
think that uh poland will decide to
leave the european union i don't think
so but let's talk about it maybe in one
and a half or two years after elections
in hungary in poland
okay i agree that poll exit is not the
danger the danger is a muddling through
and a const continual hollowing out of
the european union and its values and
its cons and constitutional setup
thank you very much to all of you for
this very uh interesting exchange and
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon
[Music]
you